je suis très heureux de vous annoncer
que avec le pfl on a lancé une nouvelle
chaîne youtube et qui s'appelle zeta
bike vous invite vraiment à elle est
checké ça l'idée de zeta bike c'est
vraiment de vulgariser non pas les
mathématiques mais l'informatique il ya
des trucs vraiment formidable à
découvrir en informatique notamment
l'informatique théorique qui est un truc
que je kiffe la mort nous on parlera
aussi d'informatique plus appliqués donc
par exemple la première vidéo qui est
sorti est une vidéo qui parle de qu est
ce qu un nombre aléatoire donc mona
parler sur scène ce soir d'un point de
vue très mathématique lie une approche
informatique et qui est peut-être la
bonne approche tout cas je la trouve pas
moins génial pour définir ce qu'est un
nombre aléatoire ou séquences de
mouvements aléatoires comme doublure est
le deuxième épisode de la chaîne d'état
bytes est une vidéo sur la machine de
turing est universel qui est le vermont
le fondement de toute la théorie
informatique etc hier un truc absolument
génial moi je pense qu'en fait les
mathématiques devrait se réduire à
l'étude des origines de turing on a le
droit peut être accéder à l'action du
choix ou des trucs un peu plus farfelues
pour essayer de découvrir des choses de
façon indirecte sur les machines turing
mais vraiment je pense que le coeur de
l'objet d'étude des mathématiques devra
être imaginé turing mais bon ça c'est
moi je suis constructivistes et tout ça
et puis à venir il y aura d'autres
vidéos sur la cryptographie ou encore
sur le machine learning et tout ça donc
plein de sujets que je trouve absolument
fantastique je vous invite vraiment à
vous abonner à cette chaîne zeta bike fl
c'est moi qui la gère et j'interviens
dans ces vidéos ne sera pas exactement
le même style que sur scène ce rôle mais
il y aura vraiment de ma touche
personnelle ou si vous avez aimé les
vidéos sur cinq forages je pense qu'il
ya de bonnes chances que vous aimeriez
aussi les vidéos que
on va faire sur des tables ait autre
chose et travail est une niche n en
anglais malheureusement on a envie de
toucher un public assez l'âge on a aussi
des professeurs le pfl qui sont pas
forcément francophone du coup l'anglais
est la langue de prédilection pour
l'informatique la recherche et du coup
je pense pour ce cette chaîne
aussi pour ça qu'on a choisi cette
langue ceci étant dit il y aura des sous
titres dans toutes les vidéos toutes les
premières vidéos en français donc
vraiment n'hésitez pas à y aller
donc voila vous pensez vraiment à aller
voir des tabacs et pensez à vous abonner
pour moi ça peut vraiment changer
beaucoup de choses puisque s'il arrive à
convaincre les gens du département
d'informatique de l'opep fait que c'est
un truc qui marche vraiment bien et qui
va nous donner beaucoup de visibilité à
leurs effets les tout ça bajeux pouvoir
travailler à temps plein sur la
vulgarisation qu'à titre personnel mais
aussi pour le développement de
l'informatique des mathématiques et leur
popularisation et puis l'éducation des
gens assure à grande échelle
je pense que c'est vraiment très très
très important que des tables ait marche
c'est un projet qui me tient vraiment
vraiment vraiment à coeur s'il vous
plaît allez voir